hey guys welcome back to Chris Lavallee
today I'll start work again strangely
enough on the Main Street this time with
a more European touch than the very
American Disney style Main Street which
I had last time and I promised that I
would elaborate a little bit more on
that concept in this video so here it
goes it's basically very much inspired
by the three world Expos that were held
in Paris quite a long time ago now which
were in 1878 1889 and 1900 and the idea
really comes from some posts on Jacques
world by Leonidas who's always been a
really big inspiration to me in
rollercoaster tycoon 3 and basically the
world Expos were where everybody got
together to Paris to marvel at the
architecture and all of the different
places in the world and where there was
a lot of Bazar and Nouveau our kind of
architecture that really stemmed from
that though please excuse me for my
French pronunciation I dropped French
class in high school because [ __ ] that
[ __ ] honestly but yeah I think it's
really beautiful and it's something
which I want to try it's maybe a bit too
well ambitious I should really say and
it's something that I definitely want to
return to in future updates in the game
when more pieces are available to
actually fit the theme because I'm
definitely stretching things and I'm
more or less using it as an opportunity
to get the general shapes of the
buildings done and just sugarcoat things
with the things we have at the moment
but it definitely won't be the exact
same style given the limitations of the
objects that we have right now so it's
it's very much like the place where this
all kicked off but it's not going to be
100% while it's going to be like
definitely not but yeah that's really
the entire idea behind what I wanted to
try in this main street this building in
particular is going to really be the
main monument and most recognizable
building of the park I should probably
say a weenie basically the issue is that
I had to have a uini
at the end of the main streets much like
Disney has their huge castle to have
that high points to look forward to
as you walk over the Main Street but I
definitely can't have a very high castle
behind this since obviously there's a
roller coaster in the way there and this
park wasn't too well planned or laid out
and in general when it comes to theme
parks there's a very important
distinction that you have to make which
is something that I haven't really
explained in any earlier videos I think
and what sort of common knowledge
amongst I think I can - yes it's
something to keep in mind is that when
you can really make distinctions between
two parks at a very basic level it's
that you have planned parks and pre laid
out plot or no I should say you have the
planned parks and the parks which sort
of grow very naturally and most of the
parks actually belong to the ones that
just sort of grow in whatever way but
you also have the parks which are
planned out like Disney and completely
built in one go and then opened and the
big difference in there is that with
parks like Disney everything really fits
together in an almost symmetrical Park
layout and everything is very well
planned whereas with other parks
everything is still planned but it grows
more organically it's much like planned
cities versus cities that grow
organically over time and this park is
definitely a park that just sort of
isn't planned really but sort of grows
but it's still quite heavily themed and
that basically meant in the end that I
ended up with having a main streets but
still not having it planned out that
well so that's one of the reasons why I
also wanted to make a more curved and
random Main Street and a very straight
Disney like Main Street which I felt
would really clash with how the rest of
the park is laid out and it's also a
problem because I obviously can't fit a
weenie in at the end of the main streets
so in the end I opted to have a weenie
in the shape of this pretty big tall
building over here which is very heavily
inspired by the Brazil Pavillion of the
World Expo in Paris 1889 which is a
really beautiful building the biggest
thing that I definitely well nearly
stole from it is the shape of the tower
which is something which I like one of
the main issue
or at least limitations I should say
with the pieces that we have in the game
so far is for melee at least that
there's a huge lack of spires like the
really fancy pointy roof type spires
that you would see on well Disney
castles or on church towers the more
like the very big eye catchers when it
comes to buildings those types of groups
are something that we don't really have
yet but I still wanted to make a
building which would be quite tall and
have this more pointy shape towards the
top and I really felt this was one of
the only ways to go about doing so still
keep everything not roof and keep it in
stone details but have a general shape
of a building which is quite tall and
really stacks up to be a very pointy
almost spider like thing to look forward
to as you're walking over the main
streets this would be the main thing
which looms over all of the other
buildings and I think it's also a pretty
good building to keep not just as a main
building to the main streets but also
for the park in general like one well
real eye-catcher of the park itself and
really this distinctive building so yeah
that's the idea behind it it is inspired
by the Brazil pavilion but it's mostly
visible in the tower and the rest was
just sort of figure out what would work
best with the pieces that we have at the
moment and definitely and not a lot of
sugar coating as well it's just a very
good opportunity to build a simple
building and then just put many details
onto it at at some point it's bound to
look good as long as you have that basic
sort of shape right which I felt pretty
comfortable with at this point in time
with having that tower over there and
this thing stick out which is going to
face a plaza in front of this building
and then alongside the side of this
though I'll still continue it at least
in the sense that there will be some
other facades next to this facade which
have the same textures and overall style
but still make them slightly different
obviously in the real theme park sense
this is going to be one
building with just facades to make it
look all detailed and nice from the
front whereas in reality this is just a
one big fake block of boring greatness
in well a realistic sense with just the
little details and decorations in front
of it I still wanted to make it seem
like it's again a couple of loose
buildings that fit together but yeah
this first part is the part that was
really most inspired by the Brazil
Pavillion and what I took most of the
ideas from really I wanted to have some
classical hints in there which wasn't
quite easy and it might actually be
possible but I still haven't really
found a way to get the very specific
classical details in there like
especially with bows are kind of
buildings I would have really loved to
have the very details of the pillars and
the things that are put on them be more
specifically like they are in real life
but I really just ended up with going
with the random things that we have in
the game to detail this building and
just sort of pop them here and there in
whatever way would seem most fitting and
it's almost really Russian and the type
that the decorations are just about
scattered everywhere but yeah that's
what basically the entire structure the
entire idea was behind making this
building look a little bit more detailed
obviously also since it is the main eye
catcher building I also want to make it
at least put a little bit more effort
into all of the detailing of the
building hands also why this episode and
corner I didn't even talk about that yet
this episode is going to consist of just
this building a couple of facades next
to it and the plaza which is going to be
in front of it because this turned out
to be quite a time-consuming thing and
I'm not even counting the couple of
takes that it took to actually get
things on the right path because as much
like these time lapses always seem like
one very smooth in-game experience
getting everything right right from the
start
there are some videos and this is one of
them in which I did miss
a couple of things here and there and
had to start over a little bit to make
the video at least a little bit less
messy and cut out some of the parts of
me building stuff and then figuring
that's not really gonna work and coming
back at it at some point in the future
so yeah here's the laying out of the
path and I really wanted to make it
quite curved and not have it completely
straight from the pot and entrance I
still have no idea how I'm actually
going to connect the pot entrance to
that but yeah that's just an issue on
look at in the future as long as it's in
the future I don't have to worry about
it yet or so I like to escape all my
problems in life so yeah I'm not really
going to worry about that too much yet
basically it's just going to be this
main plaza in front of this building and
some curvy roads around this I also
wanted to make sure to have this plus in
such a position that you would still be
able to see the tower of this building
as you actually enter the park and maybe
even as you approach the park entrance
because it's really it's really supposed
to be that Disney Castle type weenie but
you still can't really you know see it
from a very straight line as you would
have in a Main Street where everything
is perfectly straight and calculated so
I had to at least make up for that by
making sure that the curves of the roofs
were actually decent also I'm taking
every single opportunity that I can to
say the word rainy I'm not gonna lie
about that and that was this thing which
I was actually quite happy about Amy and
it's a huge well a thing that probably
took too much effort and looking back
there's actually a more a little bit
more feasible way to do this it's less
controllable but it's definitely less
time consuming as well and probably more
less poly consuming too but I basically
wanted to have red roofs and I wanted to
have red roofs at all costs so decided
to sing some signs into a roof like this
and get a red roof you can practically
get many different colors or textures by
using signs like this but it's a very
time-consuming thing way more
time-consuming than this
12 times sped up time-lapse would
probably make it seem
though that said there is still a bit of
z-fighting
in there since there are some
overlapping things and I try to at least
alleviate that a little bit by also
having the little higher up signs as
well as you can see sort of over the
signs which are all z-fighting but there
is still a little bit of sea fighting in
there and it's not the most perfect
thing but I just wanted to have a red
roof and I'm still quite happy with how
it turned out in the end and the the
rest of the roof actually almost
reminded me of like a Hansel and Gretel
house or really some of the decorations
that you see perhaps on Austrian
buildings that are painted onto the
buildings or more in that corner of
Europe as well where the decorations are
not so much balustrade or pillars but
the little curvy different textures on
the walls and especially around the
windows I had some extra details and
shapes along there which really reminded
me of that type of architecture the rest
of this building though or this building
in general I should say is not really
inspired by anything it's just a general
well let's see how this is gonna work
and let's see where this is gonna go and
if I'm gonna be happy with its type of
approach where I didn't really plan
anything out otherwise the only thing
that was really planned out and this was
something that I cut out of the time
lapse was the overall composition of the
building and this is something which you
didn't see but I did a couple of like
facade tests to kind of look at how the
building would look with different parts
attitude in different angles and
different heights and that's the type of
stuff which I think is quite important
to look at because nothing's worse than
building a building especially if it
consists of different buildings that you
can't easily copy it over to another
location nothing is worse than building
a building and then adding all of the
details to it I'm putting so much effort
into it and at the end looking back at
it and thinking well that's not entirely
the shape that I wanted to have so I
really wanted to get that in there first
and then go to all of the ridiculous
detailing like just adding random stuff
here and there and see how it would work
which is the real basic approach to all
of this especially
the balcony pieces are really useful on
this and all of the little pieces which
carry which have that same sort of
concrete texture that these roof pieces
and these balcony pieces have which is
definitely makes them very versatile
since they all have the same texture but
different shapes so you can combine them
in different ways especially if they
have those little details like the the
carvings on them as the the pirate
shields and the balcony pieces have now
the last part of this building just to
cover up whether it's going to be the
backstage part of this building really
is just another simple wall and another
Tower as well which is almost a
miniature version of the tower which I
have already I did also want to get some
red roofs in there so there's a bit more
red roof pane but aside from that it's a
pretty simple addition one of the things
which I'll also be doing with this main
street's which is why maybe this will
turn out to be my favorite episode in
the end is that definitely the other
buildings aside from this main building
are probably not going to be as detailed
or I'm probably not going to end up
being as happy with them as I am with
this building since I really wanted to
keep the main building of the main
streets also the most detailed and the
most eye-catching building of the main
streets so I probably won't put as much
effort and thought into the rest of the
buildings as I related with this with
this one which was much more planned
outs than any of the buildings I've
probably done in this entire park so far
but yeah just so you know I won't
completely throw away the main street
and just be like well then this is just
gonna have to be here and that's gonna
have to be it and just improvise
everything but it's not going to be as
detailed since this is supposed to be
that main eye catcher of not just the
main streets but probably the park in
general even though I have no idea how
this should entirely be tied to the rest
of the park it is quite a random theme
when you compare it to the theme of the
rest of the park I guess I could throw
it up on the fact that it's like a world
theme in general so using the world
exposes inspiration for it does make
some sense but it's also a theme which I
want to return to at some point in the
future because it's so very limited at
this point in time and our just certain
things which are well just impossible
given the fact that we don't have iron
girders or different glass structures
with which we can build things so it's
definitely a theme that's also best kept
I think for future episodes and
something that I'll explore a bit more
in future episodes as well with future
updates I should say but this is
religious what I wanted to try at this
point in time but I'm coming back on the
wienies I'm not sure how well I actually
went into this topic in last videos I
know I've dropped the name before but as
a general tip I would say always think
of weenies and embrace the winners
because this is the only type of context
in which you can talk about weenies and
still sound somewhat professional and
maybe actually improve on your pork
making skills kind of in the meantime
because weenies are actually quite
important especially if you want to go
for that Disneyland type Park making in
making perks and it's actually a lot of
fun as well like weenies are really
those big eye catching things that you
think about it's like Cinderella's
castle and Magic Kingdom and well all of
the other weenies that exists like the
big globe spaceship earth I think in
Epcot and it not just is something that
sort of draws people to a certain area
and is really cool to look at but it can
also really be a visual icon for the
park and I guess that's what I was
trying to make with this building even
though it's so close to the main streets
and it's really a part of it really it's
in the end it's going to be the only
building which really stands on its own
as well and it's going to be the tallest
building of the park not counting the
castle which cheats because it's placed
on the rock so I think this should
probably be the icon of grizzly Valley
it'll be hard to get used to and Pro
aisle I almost felt like the first
Alpine buildings have sort of
subconsciously become
icon of the park already but I think
this palace ash billing in general
should probably be it and yeah that's
just about everything I had to say about
weenies make sure you keep thinking
about the weenies and maybe if you're if
you want to explain stuff to your
friends or you're an aspiring youtuber
or something like that like me then
weenies are always a great topic to talk
about but yeah I just wanted to also add
some extra detailing around here and a
simple fountain which I actually came
back to an earlier idea which I had for
the old Main Street so maybe there's a
bit of legacy of the Old Main streets
this is actually very close to the old
main streets fountain I basically wanted
to have another fountain with a pillar
on top of it though I think last time I
did so I used a square pillar and I
really didn't want to do that this time
so I actually went with an actual round
pillar in this case instead and I'm not
sure what I'll exactly do with the
little things around this like maybe get
some small details about the fountain
something which I might still return to
in the future but at this point in a
video I just wanted to quickly get some
scenery in around this just so that I
could have a decent shots of the
buildings to make those look a little
bit better for the thumbnail and also
the the small cinematic shots at the end
of this video which is something which I
didn't want to miss oh whoa
which I didn't want to miss out on
either because it's something which I do
like recording as well and I do like
mashing on my keyboard and something
which is probably very helpful and
actually trying to make sense of what
these buildings would look like as you
look from the ground and not from an
increasingly sped up or very sped up
time-lapse I should say so yeah this is
what the building looks like from the
only angle from which you can actually
view the entire building at once I'm
thinking that I may actually put a
restaurant over here just because this
is a good angle to look at the
restaurant to look at this building from
but also just to keep the main streets a
little bit more open and because the
restaurants is of course quite important
to have so it's this may be an area
where I'll actually keep a larger pan
co-op
with tables and chairs and then over
here is more from the front with the
fountain in front of the building and
just the general view of the building
how it looks when you approach it from
the park entrance yeah that's basically
how it looks now in the future I'll add
some more buildings around this and fill
the main street up though also leave
some areas more open and add some
foliage here and there
so yeah that's gonna happen at least in
the next episode so thank you guys for
watching and see you later